hey what's up on today's show we're
going to talk to a
mom of a few kids who has a really
challenging relationship with her
ex-husband
and she wants to know what to do next
we're going to talk to a husband whose
new wife
has a history of drug abuse and she is
starting down a road
of sneaking prescription medication
we're also going to talk to a beautiful
soul
a wonderful mother whose son
dad and younger brother all passed away
a few years ago
and she wants to know some tools and
some tactics on how to properly grieve
her son
this is a good one stay tuned
[Music]
hey good folks what's up it's delony
with the dr john dalone show
a show where we take real calls from
real people that i've never met
and we are connecting for the first time
on this show to talk through whatever is
going on in their life whether it's
relationship challenges
marriage issues education questions
parenting challenges
whatever we talk about all things
everything on the show and here's the
thing it's not scripted
it's not a pre-imagined
it is about your life and here's the
most
important thing is that folks call me
every day
call after call after call and they feel
like they are in this
isolated bubble that these things that
they are thinking and experiencing and
wondering about and trying to figure out
are only happening to them
and the beauty of this show is that
everybody listening
my mom and her 10 friends at the at the
home
she's not in a home that sounds cool
they're all they're the only ones
listening
and um my wife didn't even listen to the
show but
those few folks that are listening get
to realize
we are not alone in this deal i'm not
crazy i'm not losing my mind
i'm going through something that so many
other people are going through we're all
in this together
and i love doing the show i learned from
this show i learned from you good folks
and um it's just an honor to walk
alongside you so whatever is going on in
your life
relational iq parenting addiction
marriage
um somebody cheated on something
whatever it is give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com show
fill out the form it goes to kelly and
her crack squad
of people i don't think she has a squad
i think it's just her but that sounded
way cooler
um and she'll just she puts the shows
together and see if we can get you on
the show
before we go any further it's important
to note this
you know we talk about all kinds of
things on the show and occasionally i
talk about something that's driving me
crazy
can we not just admit the food situation
in this country a thousand different
ways to sunday is a wreck
and we could talk about this for 50
shows in a row but here's the big one
if i go to one more store
one more aisle in a store i don't care
what store it is if it's bouged out like
whole foods or if it's a gas station
grocery store
and i go in to buy something
particularly fruit or vegetable related
and let's say i'm gonna get something
with apples in it and it's called
apple something and then there's a
sticker on it and it says
made with real apples as though that's a
selling feature
as they're like whoa this apple thing
actually has
apples in it and we all go whoo i'm
gonna pay double for it
and the the the apples were from a real
tree
no way no way good folks
when the actual product that's being
advertised
is then further advertised as actually
being in the product
as a special feature we've run aground
we're all psychotic we're idiots right
let's start demanding more from our food
from our food
labels and we're going to talk about
labels for the next
five years because the even the labels
themselves are shenanigans and
tomfoolery
but listen made with real whatever is in
it
especially if it's in the name not a
selling feature fruit juice
made with real fruit no way
vegetable juice made with real
vegetables
whoa well i call grandma on that one
good folks that one's a big one
it's ridiculous people don't if it's not
vegetable juice you have to call it
not vegetable juice or fake bull crap in
a jar that's what you should call it
unless it's actually got the product and
it's ridiculous okay
so i'm getting my blood pressure up
james we haven't started show yet
i'm telling you i saw that again on
something we bought and it's driving me
crazy
all right now i'm gonna breathe i'm
gonna control what i can control so the
pot to the kettle here
that's so that was super lame uh we're
gonna go to carol
and dallas and start off there carol
what's going on how are you
hi dr dalony thank you for taking my
call and thank you for your show you've
helped me a great deal um recently
you are hey thank you for being kind and
for saying nice things about me that
makes my heart feel good
um do you have anything in your pantry
or your fridge
that has a special label on it that has
labeled the food
for what's actually in it oh i'm pretty
sure that my nine months old
does oh for sure for sure baby food's
the worst okay
good for you it's mashed uh sweet
potatoes and there's gonna be a sticker
on it that says
contains real sweet potatoes
oh carol yes all right so hey that's not
even why you called me to talk about
food so
how in the world can i help you okay my
question is
we're dealing with a very contentious
husband okay how can i best protect and
respect my children who have very
different
points of view about their dad and
minimize
the continuing emotional and verbal
abuse towards me
gross i hate that for you all right give
me a little bit of data here how many
kids
say we have two kids um one of them is
going to be 14
on saturday and she has autism adhd and
epilepsy
and my second one is going to be 18 in
about three weeks
and she struggles with adhd depression
anxiety
and a dose of stupid
that's one of the gifts of being 18. so
it sounds like
as you rattle off those diagnosis those
kids have grown up in a somewhat
chaotic unconnected environment is that
fair
yes um we were married for 15 years and
um the marriage was filled with
emotional
verbal financial and occasional physical
abuse mostly towards me
but also my 18 year old received
a dose of
very bad verbal emotional abuse
from him man i hate that and i know you
said this both girls
is that right yes they're both girls
both girls okay
so they not only were direct recipients
of it but they
lived inside of a like a like a
vibrating cage where
the challenge is that my 14 year old
doesn't receive
any of it she is the perfect child
that could do nothing wrong and because
she has multiple diagnoses
according to her father she can do no
wrong
and he doesn't want her disciplined he
doesn't want anything happening to her
whatsoever
and he treats her like a princess
so carol make no mistake she's
definitely definitely absorbing this
no question no not in a good way
that's exactly right yeah there's no
question she's a part of this
recently he and her had a
discussion um regarding i guess she
overheard my
new husband and i talking about some of
the physical abuse or something and
certainly it's not something i talk
about to my kids but um she went to her
dad to talk to them
or talk to him about why he did it and
he told her that it was all my fault and
that i had started it all
okay so
she's confused of course she is yeah
she's 14. and here's the thing a 14 year
old
that's already wrestling with so many
connection challenges trying to put
those puzzle pieces together and make
sense of the math in her head because
right now she's got a guy
that she saw and experienced and felt
and absorbed treat her mom one way for
her entire childhood
and she has a guy who also is telling
her that he loves her will do
anything go to the ends of the earth for
her
and while she thinks that feels good
while that makes sense in her head
her brain is can't put that math
together because the math doesn't work
and you are seeing that play out in all
kinds of behavior disorders
and connection issues and abilities to
process and be still
and on and on and on and on so all of
that is there
um what's your what's your
your question how can i help in this
situation it's just messy
so how do i deal with all the craziness
that i'm getting from him
you know but with 18 year old as well i
get up to a hundred texts in a row
and i'm trying to navigate you know
i have one child to idolize another
child that
hates dad and would be happy if he never
came back again sure and so then they're
kind of arguing back and forth with
dad's this dead ball
and then i'm trying to do the right
thing and respect both of them and their
both of their opinions and i feel very
caught in the middle and i can't even
cut off the
craziness that i get from him so
um yeah a couple things here number one
you have a right and a responsibility to
both yourself
and demonstrating this for your girls
what boundaries look like
what firms strong boundaries and so
someone is not going to send me a
hundred text messages in a row
especially if they are
abusive or they are
negative or accusing or in any way gonna
hurt or set my children up for failure
and so i'm going to have boundaries like
hey we will communicate
on this day between this time please
don't send me 100 text messages ever
again
like let me know what you need to let me
know and then we're going to move on
from there
if it's more than one or two text
messages then you need to have a phone
conversation or send me an email but
don't do that to my cell phone again and
you have a right and permission to draw
those boundaries and it's it's going to
be healthy for them to see you do that
the second thing is your daughters have
this is their dad and so what more
important than what you're going to say
about him
is what you're going to model for them
and so if you
model for them as hard as it's going to
be
that they're going to be respectful and
not talk
negative and and now you're 18 year olds
an adult she's a grown up
so at some point you soon you all need
to go out and have that conversation
you're a grown up young woman you get to
make your own decisions
and um that you're going to support her
in the ways that you can especially if
she's making
healthy decisions and wise decisions but
your 14 year old's 14
and the last thing you want to do is set
yourself up to where you were talking
bad about their dad however hard that
may be
unless it gets into their psychological
and physical safety
at that point then you don't go to them
with those concerns you go to the
authorities
you go back to your original divorce
decree and you work through that system
there
but you want to model what respect and
dignity looks like
even when it's hard and now you're
playing a long game
you're not trying to win the affection
of a 14 year old you're trying to model
boundaries strength respect dignity
a powerful brilliant strong woman which
is what you are
that's what you're modeling to your 14
year old you're not trying to make her
like you right now
you're playing a 10-year 5-year 15-year
game
and someday she will go oh
my mom's incredible and she put up with
this mom why didn't you ever say that
why didn't you ever end that's when you
can be more demonstrative and open about
those
those um why you did what you did you're
18 year old man she's an adult
why won't your 18 year old cut off dad
if he's being ugly to her and
she doesn't want anything to do with him
she does to some extent she blocks him
frequently
unfortunately i then get the text
messages from
him saying that i'm a horrible mother
for letting her do that
yadda yadda so and so again right there
right there
you're going to tell him i'm will not
hold on hold on that's when you're going
to tell him
i will not receive messages from you
that are disparaging to me
we're done with that okay okay and feel
free to hold your boundary
and when he does then just respond back
and say i'm blocking you till tomorrow
because i've asked you to speak with me
to me with respect and you're not
upholding that and so we're done talking
for the day and then we'll talk the next
day
and if it continues if it escalates
that's when you call your your lawyer
back
but your 18 year old is a grown-up she's
an adult right
is she still receiving money from him
like for school
or for clothes or phone or anything like
that
she periodically goes to him and asks
him for money
but um for the most part what usually
happens
in that situation is he'll say that he's
going to do it
and then he'll either send it to her and
then demand it back for one reason or
another
or say that she disrespected him like
for christmas he was supposed to give
her a gift
and he said then that he
she had disrespected him so he was only
going to get the one child a gift and
not the other
wow okay so i think this is a
wonderful extraordinary learning
opportunity a moment for
a mom who's been through it to sit down
with their daughter
and talk about
when you accept money when you accept
gifts when you accept fill in the blank
you are then um when you
are going to call then you are opening
yourself up to all sorts of other
a b c and d's right and i think it's an
important thing you can teach her about
boundaries even if you lead with
how being vulnerable and letting her
know you haven't always been great at
setting boundaries
you've had a hard time because you loved
this guy you all
you know had two kids together there was
some good stuff there was some really
rough stuff life is hard and you are
still learning how to
set boundaries and you're going to start
practicing this stuff and
if she wants to not be around someone
that's going to be manipulative
and gaslighting and display these
these just heartbreaking
behaviors when dads manipulate their
kids like that it just breaks my heart
i think be open with your adult daughter
and let her know every time you call
back
every time you block him and say i'm
done with this nonsense but then you
call him back in a few weeks and ask for
40 bucks for the cell phone
bill um you are just inviting all this
thing back over again and that's when
you can teach her about dignity working
her butt off
setting herself up financially to be
successful all those things in a row
right
that's when that's when you can really
really begin to
make a difference in their life but what
i'm going to ask you to do
is don't don't don't don't
take the low road and bad mouth dad
don't take the unless again unless it's
a safety issue don't take the low road
don't bad mouth dad don't
run him under the ground to lift
yourself up to try to make your
daughters feel better
your 18 year old is an adult now as
young as i know she probably feels to
you
and your 14 year old is gonna watch
everything you do
so model the high road model the high
road model the high road protect those
kids
be honest when you have to and be
vulnerable and demonstrate boundaries
and now you're talking about systemic
change so these young girls
don't end up in hard situations in the
future and they learn how to walk
on firm footing on a on a firm sidewalk
and man that's legacy changing stuff
there so thank you so much for the call
let's go to uh jordan in raleigh north
carolina jordan what's up
hey what's up dr d how you doing i'm all
right brother how we doing
doing okay hey i wrote my question down
uh so if i sound like a robot it's
because i'm reading it
hey i don't write anything down and i
sound like a robot so dude
it's all good man how can i help cool
cool man so
uh hey i married my wife about a year
ago
she is a full-time paramedic and is in
pa school
over the past few months she's been
taking unprescribed xanax
on and off where's she getting it
the first time um i
had some uh i get like crazy anxiety
from flying
um so i have taken xanax
three times in my life for the past
three flights i've been on
i had a couple in a sock drawer
basically
that that was the first time she took
them um
and then the times after that she's been
uh
she found a drug dealer and has been
going to him
okay um so well it makes it a little bit
what's that go ahead man i'll i'll get
on you later we'll go ahead i want to
keep it right good you're good
yeah you're good what makes this a
little more scary is that she struggled
with heroin addiction in the past
um so i guess my question is how do i
continue to love and support her
at the same time not starting to build
up resentment
and our boundaries an option so the
first thing is to stop giving your
former heroin addict wife drugs
that's number one oh yeah yeah i did
i did not give them to her whatsoever
did she steal them from you yeah she
took them from me she did
uh they were not given to her i would
never in a million years do that ever
i'm sorry if that's what it sounded like
so
did not give them to her so when when
did she
how did that conversation go when you
found out she had stolen your your
prescription medication
so i didn't know uh because i don't i
i pull them out when i go on flights and
i don't fly very often
so i never would have known honestly i
don't plan on going anywhere
anytime soon so she told me the very
next day she took them there were
there were three in there and she took
all three um
we woke up the next morning and first
thing in the morning she said hey
there's something i gotta tell you
you're you're xanax
i took them and i i took them all and
you know
she apologized everything okay
so that was the first yeah so is she now
getting
these prescribed to her by doctor no
no she's um she's finding them
uh you know she's calling uh a drug
dealer and meeting
okay meeting with them to get them yeah
so
i'm just gonna be i have a a psychiatric
um i have a part of my will which is a
psychiatric power of attorney
meaning if i ever disassociate and i
have to be institutionalized
what do i want them to do to me while
i'm there
what do i not want them to do while i'm
there
and the addictive properties of xanax
and other benzos benzodiazepines is so
bad
i have in my psychiatric
power of attorney that if i'm
institutionalized
they are not allowed to give me that
drug wow
that's how much i hate that drug
yeah and it should never be given as a
one-off
right as a tac as a as a feel good right
yeah and so i got a problem with
whatever doctor gave them to you that
way right
and right right the second is yeah if
you've got an active addict in the home
having prescription medications is man
that's not wise
the second the second thing is
she is a paramedic dude she other
people's
lives count on her being fully present
and not
high and so this is a marriage issue
obviously one year in this is an
addiction issue one year in
and this is an also a professional
ethics issue she's going to kill
somebody man
yeah you know what i mean right now she
i do know for a fact she's not taking
these on
the job um hey listen listen brother
listen
i know but you know too right right
yeah yeah no i am i don't want to be in
the business of running your wife down
okay i'm trying to get you to realize
how serious this is
okay right and i know you know that it's
serious but um
so at the end of the day if your wife
has a heroin addiction in her past
and she is back to i'm as concerned
about the the actual narcotic as i am
about the behavior
the sneaking the off script the
um lying the then circling back and i'm
sorry it won't happen again and then i'm
going to a dealer now
all the while i'm in a really really
high stress
emotionally high strung job and by the
way i'm going to go ahead and get a
graduate degree too on top of that
you know that's probably why you called
but brother that is a recipe for a train
wreck
right right right yeah so when you sit
down and have this hard conversation
with her
how does it go what does she say um
well this is we didn't have the hard
conversation
up until a couple days ago because after
this has happened on and off for about
three months
and in between those three months it's
only happened about
um where she has come to me to tell him
to tell me that she's
you know taking a xanax um
it's only happened just a handful of
times so i do
i guarantee you you take that number
and double it you're right
but but the way we handle it from there
is thank you you know first of all thank
you for telling me
you know i know you're going through a
lot like what
you know what what's kind of leading to
this you know where are you at
mentally you know or emotionally when
you take one and you know
can we find ways to fill that hole
another way you know she likes to
you know she likes fitness and she likes
to journal and read you know so
just trying to find you know ways
to cope other than you know xanax
because i know
her job is ridiculous right right um
so this last time we we had a fight and
it kind of was me
getting to a point of like okay i've
said sorry
i've gotten over it and pressed on
and now i'm in a selfish way i guess
now i want some answers you know yeah
i think i think that's fair i think
that's super fair yeah
um and it yeah the con basically the
conversation was
you know let's uh um
basically what you know show me what
you're doing tell me what you're doing
you know to fill to fill this whole
let's you know come up with a i guess it
doesn't sound any different than it's
always been but um
right exactly and hey here's what's
going on yeah
no i and and man i'm grateful for you
and i know that you are
trying to love your wife the best way
you know how okay so i'm not i'm not
drinking a headache on that one at all i
know you're trying to love her the best
you can
um what's gonna end up happening is that
that constricting pressure those old
demons that are being
that are coming out that surfaced with
whatever trauma led to the heroin
addiction right and the things that
happened before that and i bet you and i
could talk for a long time about her
her heroine history right in her
pre-heritage history right
is that am i fair am i right on that
absolutely
okay so she she comes here whatever
stressors are going on in her life
and those demons start calling the
tendency
that you're gonna have is compassion
first
like right just like hey what's going on
how can we help hey there's just some
other things we can do
and really quick you are going to get
lumped into
the box of stressors you are going to
become part of the problem because
you're going to be something
that she has to work around because you
are holding her accountable
you've want to see these behaviors you
want to see these things change the same
as the paramedic job the same as the
grad school homework
and a partridge in a pear tree and
pretty soon she's already practicing
deceiving you
right and pretty soon that's just gonna
if it's not already
that's just gonna be common that's just
gonna be a a routine in your home
and so i i don't want to
sound any alarms unnecessarily but this
is
this relationship's on real shaky shaky
ground and i'm worried about the health
and heart of your wife
okay is she working with a professional
at all with a counselor how did she how
did she kick her heroin habit
uh rehab um and then uh
she she did some in a uh
she's done that a couple times uh she's
been in rehab a couple times in the past
and um she kicked heroin before we met
uh
was sober for a long time then left the
program
and just would do a glass of wine
every you know every other day or
something maybe
it kind of empowered her in a way that
she was like you know wow i used to not
be able to even finish up
like i used to i've been healed right
yeah i'm all good now yeah
okay right um and then this just kind of
led to
where we are now so but to answer your
question uh she does have a therapist
um she meets um over zoom
maybe once a month so here's
here's your next move uh and and i'm
i'm telling you this this is what i
would do if i was in the same situation
with the woman i love the woman that i
really want to be well and i i see her
on a
path to um destruction right
i would tell her that i and i would do
this while i'm holding her hands
right so she feels you um i would let
her know that you are
real you're terrified that's the best
word i can tell you that you're
terrified and you're scared for her and
about her and she's gonna try to make
you feel better she's gonna go into
paramedic mode she's good at that that's
what she does she goes into people's
hardest moments and brings the
the noise level down and helps them
there and
then i want you to ask her for
permission to join her in her next
session her next counseling session
because you are worried about the xanax
and the sneaky behavior and the hiding
behavior
and here's what you can do in a
beautiful vulnerable way that is also
truthful and honoring to her
you can tell her that you are struggling
with hearing her um
hearing her stories as true that you are
having frustr
you are having concerns and doubts and
fears so you're not going to call her a
liar
but you're going to let her know hey i'm
starting to struggle with these doubts
and i don't want
we're a year in i don't want our
relationship to get any more cracks in
the foundation than it needs to
i want to join you with your counselor i
want to let your counselor know what's
going on i want to be on the same page
together
i'm not helping you by giving you a
bunch of new rules and a bunch of new
behaviors that you've got to start
showing me i'm not helping but i don't
have the tools to to do this on my own
i want to join you and that's when you
are going to ask
if she lets you do this then you're
going to talk openly and candidly with
the counselor and the counselor is going
to give you some
very real and direct strategies and
tools and if the counselor doesn't
and says something dumb like well what
do you think then i want you to find
another counselor or find a marriage
counselor on zoom
and then you both are going to go do
that you're going to be vulnerable here
on two different counts number one
you're going to ask her for something
that you need and she might tell you no
and if she says you cannot join my
counseling session i refuse
then every alarm bell you have should go
off about the status and safety of your
relationship
and the second thing is is man she's
been through the ringer before
and she understands the trajectory she's
on
cognitively it's just that that
spiritual part that addiction demon man
is mean mean mean
right yeah gnarly and hopefully your
counselor
y'all's counselor her counselor will
walk you through a series of really hard
boundaries that you're gonna hold hard
hard hard
and is gonna give you some tools on how
to hold your wife with a lot a lot a lot
of grace
okay so i don't want to again be an
alarmist
your situation is real rough right now
brother
and your wife situation is rough and
scary
and she's headed not in a good direction
and again if you're listing this and
you're like dude she took three xanax
chill out she got like 10 xanax from
some dude at work what is your problem
when you have a history of addiction
when you are in a helping profession on
top of a graduate school
um a challenging graduate school program
at that
man those demons come calling and it
starts with one and it starts with two
and three and then it starts with the
i'm just gonna steal these from my
husband and i'll tell him about it later
and see how i'm gonna test the water
there oh he was kind of cool
he forgave me cool i'm gonna have
another one i'm gonna tell him about
this one but i'm
only gonna talk about every fifth one
and now we're setting up new
rhythms to our day we are lying as a
regular part of life
and the stress never gets dealt with the
pain never gets dealt with the
connection starts to fracture and
fissure with the dishonesty and suddenly
man you are full blown over your head
again
the only way through addiction is
through connection with other people
and that's what makes addiction so evil
is there's so many barriers to keep you
from having to connect and it just loops
on itself
and so hey jordan i want you to have
that hard conversation with her i want
you to ask
if you can join her and speak openly
with her counselor on her behalf
on your behalf and then i want you to
call me back and let me know how that
goes
and i'm happy to receive a call from her
if she wants to call me
she says i'm full of crap tell her give
me a shout or if she's getting scared
tell her to give me a shout and if you
want to call me back i'd love to talk to
you too thank you for that call
um these are hard hard times man
if you've got somebody in your life that
has struggled with addiction in the past
man be smart and open and
intelligent and those are all three
different things be smart and
intelligent about having prescription
medication in the house
be really weary of benzos man talk hard
with your doctor and your psychiatrist
there was a season where they were just
passing those suckers out like tic tacs
and they've reigned them in the last
couple of years just because they're so
stinking addictive
um but they are they're just passed out
like bubble gums
in in in certain pockets still i
stay away from those with every ounce of
my being and
those are tough tough tough
man brother jordan my heart's out for
you man
all right so i get this question a lot
and this is kind of a quick
detour left turn and then we'll get back
to your call i get this email a lot
um this is just an example of one this
email comes from marcus
he said you recently in i think talking
about ama article
ama podcast gave your thoughts on the
importance of reading fiction
especially before bed why is that a good
idea
all right so here's the deal with
reading fiction
i hear this a lot a lot especially in
the science communities and the nerd
communities
uh my buddies who are researchers they
constantly are saying i don't have time
to read fiction i'll have time for that
i don't
read bedtime stories dude you know how
many articles i need to be reading
there's so many great non-fiction books
and science books and research
things i can be reading i don't have
time to even read all of that
here's the thing if you talk to mental
health professionals
folks who are not just dude i just got
my degree
and just have a warm candle and take
some you time if you talk to actual
seasoned mental health researchers
to a person if you say hey give me 10
books i need to read a chunk of them are
always fiction
here's why there's two big big reasons
why and then i'll give you my personal
reason why i don't read science at
bedtime
important reason number one is there's
some there's some
psychological science and neurological
science about
reading fiction and how it helps you get
in the
heart and head of another person if you
will of a character
of what they're going through of their
body type of their environment of
whatever character arc the author has
set them on
and it teaches you empathy and you get
to practice this empathy
and experience this empathy through the
eyes of another character
your different parts of your brain take
on
fiction then they take on science
literature
non-fiction so you're actually
exercising a different part of you and
it lights up in different places
and so think of reading fiction as a
journey in empathy
as a character study as a way to learn
about people
and as a way just to get absorbed into a
story right
there's one study at the university
toronto that also talks about reading
fiction
increases creativity
you get to think about different options
remember those little choose your own
adventure books that
for those of us who are old old people
that we had when we were kids and you
get to think through i don't like that
ending i'm going to go to this ending
and then go to that ending
you get to start seeing here's the
ripple effect the domino effect of each
decision in my life
and your brain takes it on and so it's
different than just learning a piece of
science
applying science and applying you get to
see the world through somebody's eyes
experience it experience ramifications
of their decisions
and your body and your mind begin to own
those things
you get to turn off the analytical side
the quote unquote i'm reading this
because
and this sounds like i'm talking on both
sides of my mouth number one you get to
practice empathy but number two
you get to turn off the why off the
i've got to be productive with every
second of my time because if i'm not
growing i'm dying
stop dude sometimes your body just needs
to go
sometimes you just need to experience
being in the eyes and hearts of another
character
it relieves stress if you haven't just
sat
and read through the harry potter books
if you haven't sat and read through the
uh i don't know the hunger games series
that's not super cheery
but they're excellent right if you
haven't sat through and just read
through good fiction after good fiction
those are both young adult fiction which
i love
um give yourself permission to give it a
shot
give it a shot and not like kelly who
just picks up
nonfiction about more murderers and
serial killers and more death and
destruction and evil and all that stuff
hunger games is kind of but it's just
awesome but
find a series just trust me practice it
and try it
and so one other reason one other thing
that i live by is i don't read science
at bedtime when i get home from work
unless i'm in the middle of a working on
a book or a talk
i don't read science books in the
evening i don't read nonfiction and even
i read fiction
even hard weird fiction um wacky stuff i
love
um but i read it because it lets my
brain unplug from the day
and so much of us are always cramming
another podcast
another you should listen to this
podcast
but are trying to cram another podcast
another book another book
another science book another this and
man our bodies and our heads like dude
enough because then you got work on top
of that and you got relationships
enough give your heart and mind a break
start to see the world through somebody
else's eyes another culture's eyes
another group's eyes
experience the the weight of their
decisions what happens
what you would have done differently
live those things get
lost in a good fiction book give it a
shot and if it was a waste of your time
then so be it
um kelly will actually buy the book back
from you you can just eat her direct
email her directly and she'll venmo you
the money
she won't do that but that was just
funny to say all right let's take one
more call let's go to sandra
in chicago
sandra what's up hi dr dalony thanks for
taking some time with me today hey thank
you for calling is it sandra or sandra
it's sandra sandra yes okay often i miss
all right so it's so good to talk to you
is it freezing or
regular there in chicago it is well it's
regularly freezing so we are bombing 23
degrees today
23 yeah
wow that's incredible good for you
sandra all right so
what's going on and how can i help i was
hoping that you could help me uh
with some grief
tactics or methods perhaps
um so in 2018
my family had a pretty lousy year
um starting oh this would be bad for me
hold on one second
hey you're good you're good
so starting with my son's my adult son's
um heroin overdose
oh man i'm so sorry yeah and then
then i lost my dad to advanced dementia
in may
and then my younger brother in december
died suddenly
but that really the i struggle the most
with
my situation with my son
tell me about him well he um
he had a difficult life so he
as a heroin addict he would often make
bad decisions and spent a lot of time
in and out of jail so we've
so my process i feel like i've been
grieving for
or maybe grieving incorrectly for
12 15 years at least
so he um you know it's things like
every holiday yeah but even while he was
alive of course it's like well
he's in jail so he's not experiencing
this
um so i just
surround myself with guilt yeah
and you beat yourself up for who he was
as a young boy
and the situations that happened in his
life and then the
the miss dinners that turned into the
missed holidays it turned into the jail
time which turned into
yep the ultimate price so first and
foremost
um i'm heartbroken for you people aren't
supposed to have years like 2018.
and i know it's probably insulting to
you to hear all the people whining about
2020 myself included right
and i know for you you can think
you guys want me to tell you about a bad
year right um
that's that's a lot you lost
what i would be willing to wagers the
three of the most important men in your
entire life
right yeah yeah
what did what did grieving look like
with him what'd the funeral look like
what did the
the circumstances surrounding that look
like
well probably the start of a of a bad
process i would say
as you can imagine i don't deal with
these things very well
based on this conversation but uh you're
doing great oh thanks
well we so we did a private uh
service with just the immediate family
yeah and you know i don't
i didn't want i first of all i didn't i
don't know friends i mean i don't know
people i didn't know people to contact
and
and things like that for him and then
for
us you know our outside circle of
friends and associates and things um i
just couldn't do a day of
handling
it was hard to you didn't want to answer
questions and have to
do the reception line and yep exactly
so it was just it was just immediate
family
so sandra um this is going to be either
easier said than done
but you've got to stop judging yourself
you've got to stop being ashamed of the
person your son was
yeah right and i know every single mom
the moment they hold that little baby
boy they
have man i've listened to my wife fast
forward
you know in year one i hope i like his
wife and i'm like what
right and i think we're gonna have the
wedding and you're like
we we we gotta slow the roll right um
i know that every mom holds that little
baby and
just a narrative unfolds right a story
unfolds
and it is really hard when every morning
you wake up here we are two years three
years later and that story's not gonna
happen
right it's not gonna come true the more
you avoid
putting a period at the end of that
story the more you continue to carry
those bricks of
i failed as a mom my son was a failure
as a guy as
long as you hold that shame that
identity
as a grieving mom um it's gonna beat you
up spiritually and psychologically
your health is gonna suffer from that
and i want you to know
you're worth more than that oh thank you
you don't believe that but i'm telling
you and i want you just to
get on youtube or listen to this podcast
over and over and just hit refresh
refresh on that
you are worth grieving this you're worth
holding your head high
and you are worth living the rest of the
years that you've got left
boldly and unapologetically and with the
new spirit of meaning about it
okay
no you bet you bet and do all of us
wish we could take things back as if
from our kids childhood
yup right and
so those things that may have happened
that you think through that pop into
your head
here's what i want you to do i want you
to consciously
whether you've got to say out loud and i
have to do this to myself sometimes
when that thing that conversation that
you had when you were a kid or that
thing that happened where you when he
was young and you wish you could have
done it differently or
your husband said this one thing and you
sh i want you just to
if you have to yell it but just say
stop right say it out loud
nope because at this point moving
forward i want you to
consider those intrusive thoughts those
shameful moments those
well if you'd only thoughts i want you
to
say no i want you to listen to the i
mean i want you to know those are now
decisions from this point forward
and focusing on those won't help your
son
focusing on those won't help heal your
heart they're just going to keep you
chained to the shame and shame to the
chained to the past
right yeah so you said something earlier
that i
i really want to lean on and i want you
to listen to me closely okay
okay there is no such thing as an
incorrect way to grieve something other
than not grieving at
all and this is
three years two and a half years you're
getting up right you're about a month
and a half away two months away you're
getting up on
the third anniversary and it's gonna
those little anxiety bells are gonna
start ringing louder and louder remember
remember right
and then you're gonna enter what i would
probably assume is gonna be a dark
season
when your body remembers 2018
right one loss after another loss after
another loss there
is not an incorrect way to grieve that
other than to shove it down and act like
it's not happening
okay so here's a couple of things that
i've
walked alongside folks that they've
found helpful in the past that i've
found helpful in the past
number one you cannot cannot under
any circumstances sandra grieve by
yourself
okay so this is the time and i know it's
super annoying and hard with govid
especially in the city like chicago
you've got to find somebody
a small group an individual a counselor
somebody
that you can say out loud i'm not going
to be ashamed of my son anymore
i'm going to choose to remember the
great good stuff about him he probably
had a sweet sweet soul
i'm gonna remember the joy and fun that
we had when he was younger
i'm just not gonna focus on the negative
stuff because it doesn't do anybody any
good
and i want you to experience that
vulnerability and that shame letting i
want
you've got to do that with somebody else
okay that's going to be vulnerable
moment number one for you
vulnerable moment number two is i want
you to write him a letter
that tells him about what in the craps
going on in 2021 and that you miss him
like crazy
i want you to write him a second letter
possibly with this person right and i
want you maybe you read it to this
person
if you're super hardcore and vulnerable
and tough
i want you to write him a second letter
and tell him that you're heartbroken
that he left you
okay because it's okay to be angry with
him it's okay to be
frustrated with him it's okay to be
really really pissed off at him
and then the third letter i want you to
write him
and tell him um who you're becoming
but i want you to write it as though you
want him to know how proud of
you he should be because you're gonna be
the mom who now you're going to go take
dance lessons once they
the lockdown is over and you're going to
learn spanish
and you're going to start delivering
meals on wheels you are going to start
living this shame-free this
unfettered life that's not going to be a
forgetting of him
not going to be forgetting your dad not
even forgetting your brother but it's
going to be in celebration up it's going
to be meaning making of
and when you get a group and you spend
some hard hard minutes writing these
letters to them
uh to your to your son and they don't
have to be all the same day especially
shouldn't be on the same day
when you do this what's going to start
to happen is you're going to start to
smile
you're going to start to heal a little
bit you're going to have good days you
have real bad days and on the bad days i
want you to go
well that's my body trying to take care
of me again i want you to smile at those
days and then get back under the covers
if you need to
and if you got to go to work you got to
get up and that's where you're going to
reach out to your buddies and to your
friends because you can't do this alone
and over time you're going to begin to
make meaning here
and what making meaning looks like is
different for everybody
it may be you joining a group to go talk
to young boys who are getting into drugs
it may be you writing letters to young
addicts in
jail and letting them know that hey
their mama loves them
and that you will be there when they get
out
it may be that you're going to help knit
and crouch i don't know what i don't
know what you do you may
you may build machine guns there i don't
know what you do but you're going to be
making
meaning for the rest of your life
sounds like a good idea but here's the
all of this is under one giant shell
which is this
you have to decide i'm not gonna wear
the identity
i'm not gonna consider myself a failed
mom
i'm not gonna consider myself somebody
who's just grieving for the rest of
their life
is the ache of the loss of your son
always gonna be there dang right it is
he was your baby boy
but that's not going to define you
you're going to have to let that go and
letting that go is going to feel like
you're letting him go
yeah okay and you are going to have to
moment where you have to have a moment
where you let him go and that's when you
get to live in those joy
the however few they are however many
they are
that's when you get to live in those
joyful joyful moments
so i wouldn't wish 2018 that you
experience
on anybody even people i can't stand
being around that's heavy and hard
heavy and hard i'm sorry you experienced
that
if you want to be real brave sandra when
you get a chance
when you write one of those letters i'd
love for you to call it in
and read it out on the show
i think that would be healing for
millions of people who are experiencing
disconnection from their kids
who are heartbroken over you know
children who've made choices that they
don't agree with that are
locked them up all those struggles i
think that'd be a beautiful beautiful
moment
um that's hard though that's really hard
you don't have to do that but man that
it would be a blessing thank you so much
for that call sandra we love you
and we care about you
all right so we're going to end the show
on a totally
180 degree positive note i'm going to
leave us out here with a smile on her
face
actually it's kind of a depressing song
but i mean it in a positive way okay
so i'm gonna take us all back to my
childhood
small little green puppet
in love with the pig
the frog was doing everything he could
to win this pig's affection the pig say
no pig said no the pig said no and the
frog said
it's not easy being green and he wrote a
little song and it goes like this
it's not easy being green having to
spend each day the color of the leaves
when i think it could be nicer being red
or yellow or gold or
something much more colorful like that
it's not easy being green it seems you
blend in with so many
other ordinary things and people tend to
pass you over because
you're not standing out like flashy
sparkles in the water
or stars in the sky right
but green's the color of spring and
green can be cool and friendly-like
and green can be big like the ocean or
important like a mountain or tall like a
tree
when green is all there is to be it
could make you wonder why but
why wonder why i wonder i'm green and
it'll do just fine it's beautiful and i
think it's what i want to be
and i really want that pig to love me
this has been the dr john deloney show
[Music]
you